the divisive nature of american politics
has seen the threat against politicians
rise four-fold in the last year
even at the u.s capitol one of the most
protected buildings in the world
capitol police couldn't protect them
an angry mob storming congress amid
claims of a stolen election
five people died in the attack and
elected officials were left fearing for
their lives
in the weeks that followed a huge
military and security presence
surrounded capitol hill
and many politicians stepped up their
own personal security
some even buying body armor or carrying
a firearm retired major general linda
singh was one of those tasked with
reviewing their security the key thing
is how can we ensure their safety but
yet allow them to do what they're hired
to do right i mean they're elected to be
out in the public and so how do we
get that fine balance and how have you
struck the balance
well i think it's challenging i think
it's challenging because every member as
you can imagine has their own view of
security and so one of the things that
you know you really have to do is to get
personal with that individual to say
okay how are we going to work this what
works for you may not work for the next
person
congressional spending on private
security has surged among members of
both parties since january the sixth
attack
republican liz cheney spent 58 thousand
dollars on protective measures in the
first three months of this year after
publicly denouncing donald trump for
inciting the violence
fellow republican senator mitt romney
spent more than 43 thousand dollars on
security after voting to impeach the
former president
u.s politicians don't usually meet
members of the public without an
appointment and when they hold town
halls which is about as close as you get
to a constituency surgery over here
they're allowed to expense security
detail and body armor but if they want
security at home or bodyguards for when
they're out and about they have to pay
for it themselves the most recent
targeted attacks on individual members
of congress include democrat gabrielle
giffords who was shot at point-blank
range during a constituents meeting
outside a supermarket in arizona ten
years ago she survived
in 2015 senator clementa pinckney was
killed in a mass shooting at a historic
black church in south carolina in what
was thought to be a hate crime political
spending on security here is roughly
three times what it was two years ago
members of congress feeling increasingly
threatened by the very public they're
elected to represent
sally lockwood sky news washington